this is the best time of my life
jennifer lopez praises her fiance ben
affleck on father's day and gives a rare
look inside their family life with her
kids mom i will take the best care of
this cat like i don't think you
understand i will pamper it with
everything that i have you hear that
sincerity yeah i hear it not only that i
have it on tape j-lo shares a snippet of
14 year old emmy pleading her case to
get a new pet and ben he's on team emmy
listen it's time to love again it's time
to love a cat again
please it's time for you to open your
hearts to a cat again you can do they
leave brady they don't leave all the
time they leave listen
the only experience you love them and
then they leave you mom this kind of cat
will not leave you they need humans
he's going to leave when it dies but all
things change
all things change life is strange just
keep getting counted
again
looks like ben is fitting right into the
fam and the singer can't stop gushing
about building a blended family with her
man
this is the best time of my life jen
posted this instagram dedication to ben
for father's day filled with lots of pda
and cute moments together i love my
career but nothing is more fulfilling to
me than being able to build a family
with someone who i love deeply and who
is just as dedicated to family and and
to each other as we can be and uh
i'm just i feel incredibly blessed
but jen wasn't done she continued to
brag on her man on her blog on the jlo
writing about how lucky she feels to
have a front row seat to ben's role as a
dad
quote i have never seen a more
consistent loving and selfless father
and it's not just to your own kids but
also without obligation to mine as well
and we see why j-lo is so smitten i feel
great thank you seems like the feeling
has been the same since the marry me
star announced their engagement back in
april it was totally unexpected
my love came in ben came in and he got
down on one knee
and he said some things that i'll never
forget
and then he pulled out a ring
and he said will you marry me
and it was
the most perfect moment
feeling so lucky it's not often you get
a
second chance at true love
we feel very lucky i love you
i love you too
ben and jen don't have any kids together
but will soon become one big family jen
shares 14 year old twins emmy and max
with mark anthony and ben is raising his
kids violet seraphina and son samuel
with jennifer gardner it's great and
jen's second shot at love couldn't come
at a more perfect time as she continues
to thrive in her career by her side
through it all ben who makes a quick
cameo in jen's netflix documentary
halftime
i said to her once
doesn't this bother you
and she said i'm latina a woman
i expected this you just don't expect it
you expect to be treated fairly
and when et spoke with jen at the
premiere she gushed over having her
man's support ben featured in the doc as
well how full circle of the moment is
this for you though it's a beautiful
moment
[Music]